well we're very lucky to have with us
the foreign office minister james
cleverley this morning hello to you
morning thanks for coming in uh what's
the deadline
for these talks to actually conclude
well look
we will keep negotiating until the point
where
there can be no further negotiating or
until a deal is done so exactly
exactly when that is i don't know but
we're we're working to get a deal
there is still the opportunity it's
still a possibility of getting a deal
um and we'll keep working to the last
possible moment but it has to be passed
by parliament it has to be translated
into a couple of dozen languages it has
to be ratified
by all of those european countries there
must be a time when is it the end of
this week is it the 20th is it christmas
eve
we know it has to happen soon it's got
to get through as you say it's got to
get through
our parliament and i'm pretty sure that
uh all the members of parliament who
have said that they really really want
the uk to have a trade agreement before
the end of the implementation period
i'm sure that they will want to back
this and if suddenly they decide not to
there there'll be some interesting
questions to ask about
about why not and so that will take a
period of time but as i say
um david frost and negotiating team will
keep working
until the the point where as i say
either we run out of time
or until we get a deal done so that's my
question when do you run out of time
because parliament rises
the week before christmas well as i say
there's i mean i don't have a particular
kind of day or minute
uh the one thing we have learned with
with uh eu negotiations and it's not
unusual in negotiations is they often go
to the
right to the last minute of the 11th
hour so
uh whilst it would have been lovely to
have got something agreed earlier than
this it's it's not completely surprising
that that that this is this is going to
the wire but as i say we'll keep
negotiating hard
on behalf of the british people to get a
good trade agreement
to get a deal done uh and we'll we'll
use as much time as we've got available
and could the exit be delayed no the
prime minister is really clear on this
the prime minister is really really
clear on this
the implementation period is going to
come to a conclusion at the end of this
year
we would like that to be concluded with
a trade agreement but ultimately we're
not going to sign up to something
which which doesn't deliver on what
people voted for doesn't deliver on that
sovereignty doesn't deliver on
the uh you know the integrity of the uk
or
it doesn't deliver on on phishing for
example so we're going to make sure
we've got a good deal for the uk
i think that is possible um and that's
what we're working towards
so the internal market bill is due to
come back today
that's going to be delayed i'm guessing
because you won't want to upset the
european union
well the internal market bill contains
really important clauses that protects
the integrity
of the united kingdom some of which were
taken out by the house of people yeah
and they will be put back
in the background they will be put back
and that will look at the european union
well
i mean if if if that is the case that is
unfortunate but ultimately
this is an insurance policy it's really
important
like all insurance policies you would
prefer not to have to use it
but if it's needed it's better it's
better that it's there and it is about
protecting the integrity of the united
kingdom as a single entity
any prime minister who is blase about
protecting the integrity of the united
kingdom shouldn't really be in that
in that job and the prime minister is
really key he's really clear
this is a key part of protecting the
integrity of
the country that he is prime minister so
just to clarify it will go ahead today
the internal market bill
it's not going to be delayed even if it
upsets members of the european union
as i say when we're at such a delicate
time of negotiations well
it contains clauses that we may need to
rely on
and and if we do need to rely on on them
better that they're there
even though they break the law in a
limited and specific way
as i say it's an insurance policy we
would prefer like all
like all insurance policies you would
prefer not to have to use it
but you would kick yourself if you need
it and it isn't there
yeah but if you're negotiating and
they're at such a delicate stage
really do you want to take that risk why
not just delay it but
but actually not having that in place
would weaken our position
and actually give an advantage to the eu
negotiators and actually in a
negotiation like this
it is really key that both parties
negotiate hard and i'm sure
the eu negotiators are negotiating hard
uh
but so is uh david frost and our
negotiating team
um we do it in a spirit of positivity
but we do want to get a deal that works
for the uk and an agreement that works
for the uk what happened to the oven
ready deal
that happened that was the withdrawal
agreement as you know okay
that was the withdrawal agreement which
was voted through shortly after the
general election
and actually i know a lot of people have
been have been using that oh you we were
promised another ready deal
and that oven ready deal was delivered
and the people who are now using that
phrase
about this trade agreement are either
displaying their ignorance or their
dishonesty one of the two
okay so you don't feel that that they
too uh
worked at melded together no i don't
feel because that isn't the case the
the oven-ready deal as you know was the
withdrawal agreement
which was signed up to by all the
conservative candidates at the last
general election where we got a solid
working majority
and we delivered it through the house of
commons just like the prime minister
promised we would okay if we don't have
a deal
um what does that mean for our borders
in relation to getting goods to and from
the european union
well without a doubt having
a trade agreement makes it so much
easier
there will be changes and the uh the
government has put out an information
campaign to encourage businesses to look
at what changes
they will need to conform to there will
be changes whatever happens
um it will be easier if we get a trade
agreement but we have been
are working very very hard to ensure
that even in the event that we don't
have a trade agreement
we still will be able to trade
internationally but there will be
changes
because the chairman of the rhode hall
is association says there'll be
significant disruption for up to 12
months if we don't have a deal
well as i say this is this is why we're
we're working hard in good faith to try
and get an agreement
there will be changes whatever happens i
think people need to understand that
there'll be fewer changes if we do get
this agreement and that's what we're
working
towards um it's not possible for anyone
to
predict with certainty what the
implications will be but we're not going
to sign up to an agreement that doesn't
work in the interests of the
of the uk it is possible to get one
one that works for the uk and the eu and
that's what we're working towards
what about our vaccines how are we going
to get them from belgium so
we have we've got extensive plans in
place to ensure
the protection that vaccines apply as
you can imagine that is the
absolute priority product um and we
we are committed to make sure that we
will get that that vaccine supply
to the uk what plans well we've got
uh we've looked at uh use of
non-commercial flights we've got board
arrangements in place we will ensure we
will
absolutely ensure order arrangements
well i haven't got the uh
the details to hand but as you can as
you can imagine
um everyone understands the significance
of vaccines these people like people's
lives at stake i have no doubt
if it's stuck in a lorry three miles
back how are you gonna get it i have no
doubt
that the eu uh will will help us to
uh facilitate uh travel we've got our
own independent
uh transportation plans to ensure
that that vaccine supply will come so
it's going to be airlifted in
amongst amongst other things okay and
you think that we will be able to jump
the queue with the vaccine oh absolutely
i have
absolutely no doubt i've absolutely no
doubt they want to help us
if we don't agree a deal why would they
want to help us with anything else i
i i don't i don't have that degree of
cynicism towards the
towards the eu let's see um
the little card that i've seen in the
papers today for when you've had your
vaccine
that's basically a passport isn't it
that's a vaccine passport
well ultimately what we're looking to do
is
get this vaccine rolled out as quickly
as possible the
joint committee on vaccination
immunization have
uh put forward their advice in terms of
the prioritization
of the of the vaccine to protect the
most vulnerable our key workers
and then at the various age bands so
that we can so we can get this rolled
out uh
quickly and start working back towards
um uh the uh the lives that we were used
to living
and so and so actually having confidence
uh is important and
and and that's what the that's what the
rollout plan is i have no problem with
the vaccine passport but michael gove
sat there last week and said we were
definitely not having one and yet we see
these cards in the papers today
well as i say the the priority is about
making sure the rollout
uh um is first the most vulnerable
also to our to the people look after
them and our uh key workers in the
in the medical profession what is it if
it's not a passport
it's i mean ultimately it it's about
it's about making sure that there is a a
wide roller and confidence in that roll
out as well
so so so um it's a passport isn't it
it allows you to go into places that you
wouldn't be able to go if you didn't
have it
it's about unlocking it's about
unlocking people's lives it's about
unlocking the economy it's about making
sure
we we protect lives and protect
livelihoods well there you go we get it
but it's a passport
and your colleague would say it's not so
you know politicians when they come on
my program i don't
i expect them to be as honest as you and
tell my viewers exactly what's happening
he sat there less than a week ago saying
we weren't having them and we quite
clearly are
is that okay well as i say um
i and i think i think everyone would
agree i regard the most
important thing is ensuring that we can
use the vaccination
program to protect the most vulnerable
protect our key workers
and get back to life arguing over the
semantics of of the delivery of that
is great you know i get that but for us
the priority is making sure
it's not arguing is making sure that
this program
allows us to get back to normality as
well i wonder what you make of all those
images of the christmas shoppers
over the weekend flooding into areas
it is frustrating it is frustrating
um the vaccine without a doubt
is a light at the end of the tunnel but
ultimately we still have to
exercise personal responsibility we are
not there yet it will take some time
to roll this vaccine out and it will
take some time before we go back to
normality i get it
you know people want to get back to
normal but let's not rush this
we're nearly there let's not rush this
okay another couple of thoughts just
while i've got you um
millwall you saw at the weekend the
booing
um thought on that first of all the
booing is wrong
the booing is wrong you know we all have
our views over black lives matter as an
organization as an agenda
but ultimately the fight against racism
particularly the fight against racism in
football
is is really important kick racism out
of football is a fantastic organization
it's been working on this for
many many many many years i think it was
i think it was
wrong and the people who did it i think
should just think a little bit about the
message they send about what is
our national game should there be action
taken against them because it's not
difficult to know who they are
people in the ground were there yeah i
think i think action taken against them
i'd be a bit uncomfortable with but i
think the message should be really
really clear
unacceptable totally unnecessary there
are players on on the pitch and more
widely
doing uh something that they believed
strongly sent a positive message about
their fight against racism
and and doing that i think is wrong what
do you think about the organization
black lives matter because you know your
colleague george eustis was on the
program uh
yesterday and he referred to them as a
political movement well
it it seems that elements of that are
drifting towards the
the political sphere i think the more
broad i think the
the the the broader point that many many
people
are are trying to make which is
absolutely right
is that the uk is a country that stands
uh uh in opposition to to racism that is
absolutely right
absolutely right i do think some people
involved with the black lives matter
movement particularly in the the
you know the center of it uh have said
and done things which i believe to be
counterproductive but the but the
broader agenda is obviously the right
thing to do
um my mother is from west africa of
course you know we want to see racism
eradicated in the uk but as i say i
sometimes think some of the words and
actions are counterproductive to their
to their
desired aim so would you describe them
as a political movement
as i say some clearly some elements are
drifting in that direction which
which which i think is which i think in
some instances makes it hard for them to
deliver what they're saying they want to
deliver
um what job do you want in the reshuffle
i
speculating about reshuffles is a fool's
game
uh i've got a fantastic i got a
fantastic job uh
in the in the in the foreign office uh
one of the real
frustrations for me personally and
professionally
about covid is that a job that normally
enables you to
you know meet people and travel around
the world has been massively restricted
so i've only just started doing the job
fully and properly so you know as i say
speculating that reshuffles i'm not even
going to go how many covert tests have
you had
oh i've lost track i've lost track um
six seven eight loads never and they
never get easier
no so you're looking forward to the
vaccine oh yes oh yeah but
i'll take my turn i'll take my turn i'm
not in one of the higher risk groups so
for the
for the time being because politicians
are queuing up to have them done on this
show so well look i hear what we can do
you know i'm quite
i'm quite happy when my turn comes i am
quite happy to
you know do it publicly i'll give you
the card and maybe a lollipop as well
sticker i've been a good boy there you
go it's good to talk to you i know
you're busy thanks very much indeed for
joining us appreciate it thank you